okay what to play tell me the first move
chats what's the play first move
c3 okay John wins c3 what is this I'm
imagining c5 d 4 takes and then why
can't play e4 I thinking I would
transpose to a Smith Maura
but there's aunt lisanna
again the pony's not here I feel like so
many people challenge me and then forget
that they challenged me and then they
probably Oh ones here ok so how can I
justify c3 what's the purpose of this
move before pawn chain actually I
remember I went to New York years ago I
played in Washington Square Park and
there is some street hustler that was
playing this c3 before and he is
actually a decent player he followed up
with d3 I was just kind of a reverse old
Indian he would just do this this and
it's just weird to start with c3 before
but it's playable honest people sing
king a queen 8th floor and some
alternate universe King a4 would be
checkmate c5 interesting comes by a3 I
want to maintain my pawn structure I've
greatness of g2
[Music]
yeah the way to remember openings in
chess that helps when you have stories
attached to them there is some part of
is memorizing the moves but when you
have some experience it becomes easier
to just remember snippets of information
[Music]
yes so the whole point of this is
basically I do my own thing
block does their own thing and then we
have some game so far
blocks playing very reasonable and it
could be anywhere from 1600 to I'd say
2300 so I mean the goal of the subtlest
alii for I'll prepare with her key one I
[Music]
mean the dream is a 45 and forking oh
[Music]
you're moving to Chicago soon
I'm not actually in Chicago but as far
as I understand the whole city is shut
down but yeah if you if you play chess
go to North Avenue beach there's a small
chest pavilion and usually it's um yeah
it's it's busier in the good weather
months so summertime hopefully things
will reopen there should be seven feel
like black develops like very naturally
and now just doesn't know what to do but
Bishop e7 was maybe maybe hearing my
plan of v45
but I want to play e5 anyway and kick
the night and maybe eventually d4
[Music]
North Avenue beach is underwater Oh to
the water
rious that's unfortunate
well there are some staple openings saj
defenses - no his black I mean really
you just need two main defenses of black
one some things I playing in c4 and
something to play against d4 and
sometimes your defense against d4 can
also apply to like English in 9f 3u5
interesting move like we need to just
slow and steady
do I like Mozart's I'll admit I don't
listen to Mozart in my free time but I
probably like Mozart more than I like
death metal
[Music]
[Music]
we've kind of turned into this actually
looks like a Kings Indian the tap and
the general plan of the structure is to
play like night h4 f v o is hoping for
Mozart Alexa play Mozart's Amazon music
wait
well it's art has a first name
interesting play another five probably
95 is Bishop f8 g6 a nine if they're 93
I don't know this Bishop each three
I just want to rip open the kingside how
to do it let's bring the other night at
five on two nights when I five it'll be
a super night yeah I had no idea of
Mozart's first name was was Wolfgang
there's new information that brah
that probably means Beethoven also has a
first name Alexa what's Beethoven's
first name learning something new all
right let's play this move cuz now I
just want to take the bishop or do i
I'll be h4
yeah Ludwig actually rings a bell but
Wolfgang doesn't ring a bell on there's
Bach it's box first name probably I will
be play this move I know I'll lose a
pawn bishop here like g4 let's play g4
pawns are meant to be pushed
Oh Johan yeah Johann Sebastian Bach I
knew that it's hard when I think I have
it more difficult than other people
because I have to like try and keep
track of all these names in the chat
there's only so much room in memory for
names
Givenchy I'll just forget some what's
harder than this famous people all right
let's play this is exactly what I want
this kind of happy structure that's like
oh why
[Music]
well played Bishop Siwon and maybe
someday sack
I won't forget tog II as long as there's
an emotes there's an emote for it I
won't forget it
all right let's play rook ones putting
up a fight sui bishops he won I'll play
this move next at this point I'm
guessing like nineteen nineteen seventy
[Music]
quiz what is Harry's last name formerly
known as Prince Harry as a potter also
didn't Prince Harry one of the princes
got covet right Harry Mason I don't know
yeah do not ask me trivia questions
let's play it's late g5 it's got some g5
you months need moar emotes in the chat
this is looking very nice this is now a
kind of like a tea queen g4 will
complete the tea but it might hang a
queen I'm threatening to take tho
[Music]
there's so many ideas is each six it's
taking this pawn is hanging probably
don't care about this pawn
[Music]
well h6 because yeah the nice kind of
pain is so I don't want to take a tinge
piece I'm guessing like nine let's say
1920 like opponent played kind of mean
opponent didn't really blunder at all
but just kind of got outplayed
gradually my meaning yeah this looks
pretty promising
[Music]
hmm teenage seven
yeah let's go for this anyway goes to
remove this rook what are those those
emojis some kind of symbols yeah so if
rook takes this tricky move that's kind
of nice
it's incredible like I'm not meeting
even though I have like all these pieces
and black really just has a bishop and
pawns defending but the rook is gonna be
the final straw and there's a funny line
I'm kind of hoping for rook takes g3
takes f6 King h8 Queen g8 would be mate
but more fun as Queen g7 and then pawn
xj7 mate yeah we're not going into that
oh good move
wow the points resourceful let's play
this move there's no way Bach surviving
much longer
what playlist is this is just Mozart
just tell tell it to play Mozart this
reminds me of a horror movie
why not meeting here I might not be
meeting like I don't want to trade
Queens
there's this crazy move idea takes and
then takes I dare give away all my
pieces does that work
Queen d1 here here here and the ninety
would be rook takes g6 I give away that
because whenever this happens I'm eight
only issue is oh no that's not an issue
but [ __ ] takes here I just I feel so
wrong doing this there goes like Queen I
could I could be losing all my pieces
I'm basically trying to basically
sacking my queen and both rooks I'm
black to take with check oh that's not
maids oh but I'm winning the Queen oh
but this is probably really bad for me
it was just a complete miscalculation
but once a long time I don't know what's
gonna happen here
I forgot about that move - Wow
so many things I forgot about that
doesn't work I'm just losing this this
is so bad
okay now this music sounds like horror
music
[Music]
I was I could've won easily - what to do
trying to figure out the trickiest path
forward this is really bad
[Music]
she solder doesn't work only has 12
seconds and there's some increment
apparently
my whole advantage evaporates there
there
oh this is not good and staring at the
position is not gonna help I don't know
why I did that
I just thought it was me I I saw this
and meet
I forgot I could defend so easily you
tried this move takes it doesn't work
either though
[Music]
um just try this and hopefully the vests
[Music]
well blocks about to flag a Hobbiton
flag
I have to I've yeah I have to allow a
lot to keep the Queen oh that's a very
good move good move
I'm dead Pinkerton her girl's gotta save
flack - let's do this let's do this and
let's meet well I came back I came back
wow I won that
oh wow well they come back what just
happened
that wasn't bad that was that was really
bad
that was really bad I was really bad
that was such a terrible display of
chess I'm sorry man I hope this
I hope this music isn't copyrighted
otherwise YouTube will like bad me but
this is definitely is Mozart copyright
now
it's not copyrighted right it's like
open open source and source music yeah
it's going on YouTube the title of this
video will be that was really bad yeah I
I was trying to be clever Quinn do you
want such a bad move man
what's a better move maybe I'm not
meeting
wow I'm hardly worse because I I've let
black take all my queen side pawns I
have to trade Queens so if I go back
yeah this was a very nice maneuver
[Music]
quite good Equis exactly to the victory
with that way yeah I'll bring I'll
brainstorm some titles and yeah like
everything was completely winning I was
so proud of rook t32 apparently bishop
c8 saves plaque it's incredible does
this work g3
Wow 97 it's incredible that blacks
defending with like this dawn set up
against this such powerful setup
computer says plus 0.2 but the end the
end was ridiculous it's like I gave away
a queen I gave away both rooks I ok the
second rook can't be taken I was so
proud of this too because I I saw this
position from afar and thought oh I'm
just meeting and for some reason I
thought this is also mate and thought
black can't defend this and I just my
knight comes to g6
I just forgot that like every black move
basically defends yeah if I was a poet
consider naming at that no as I saw this
position that this just this made me
really excited that I would give away to
Brooks and a queen and this would be the
knick knack paddy sack wag attack at
Bishop e7 evergage one of the great
rook t1 was made in but the opponent
wanted to humiliate me by promoting the
pond so rook t1 was made here and there
was also me here yeah I made use with
what I have left
thank you doctor doctor DSM so the yeah
the sent upon loss was was also not so
impressive man I don't know if I can
play more chess after that well is that
game